When your customer says,
"Why do I have to give my
information on every device?"
she really means,
by using AI for data and applications,
you can predict my needs
and provide a better, more
personalized experience across any channel.
When your customer says,
"What's the best deal for me?"
he really means,
you can automate repetitive
tasks and increase my engagement
by enabling more rapid
and effective responses
based on data-driven insights.
When your customer says,
"I don't feel comfortable providing my personal information,"
she really means,
by securing your business
against cyber threats,
you can protect my personal information from a security breach.
IBM Cloud Paks are AI-powered software
that can help advance digital transformation
through prediction, automation, and security,
allowing you to modernize
across any hybrid environment,
from the data center,
all the way to the edge,
change how you work,
how your business works,
and most importantly,
how you serve your customers
with IBM Cloud Paks.